i had a really fun time watching the
movie last night and sophie i really
want to get started off with you
just by asking you to introduce the
movie to somebody who's maybe going into
this completely blind and maybe talk a
little bit about what inspired you to
work on this story
sure hello yeah um
look the film is called good luck to you
leo grant and it's about a woman who um
hires a sex worker to have good sex for
the first time in her life um
and it's about these two people nancy
and leo meeting across a series of
meetings and sort of and investigating
things about their lives like bodily
pleasure and their own bodies but also
their kind of emotional landscape as
well and um
what inspired me to get involved look i
got sent a script that was about this
woman hiring a sex worker and exploring
pleasure
um and
emma was attached to it and i just
thought the combination of those two
things was completely irresistible like
i just thought there's no way i can't do
this this is everything i'd love to lean
into to explore something between two
people um
so intimately
and um for emma and daryl nice to meet
you first of all um i want to know what
drew you to your respective roles and
what you maybe learned for from the
process of filming this movie uh and
emma will start off with you first
um well it wasn't the money um
um i uh
sometimes it is i'm just saying you know
i'm always gonna have to earn my living
it's very important um
no it was it was just the script was so
extraordinary i know katie brown who
wrote this group she's an amazing writer
and a fantastic intellect as well and um
and she's she'd written it and said what
do you think you absolutely have to make
this you have to because it was sort of
fully um formed she'd had the idea and
then it had just come out in that way
that sometimes things happen
and uh
um so
there was it was just a no-brainer i
hadn't read anything that ex
examined this woman who ticked all the
woman boxes the woman's shape boxes yes
tick mother yes tick wife yes teacher
pillar of the community yes tick
excellent really good well done and
she's 62 and hasn't had an orgasm
so there's a lot missing
so and and so this is her journey but of
course the journey involves her
um dismantling
every
moral precept that she's built her life
on so it's an act of great courage and
and not and anarchy
so that's what's not to love
amazing and daryl what drew you to this
role um yeah i just received the script
um early last year and i was reading it
and um
quickly saw that it was a two-hander
film with these two people in the hotel
room and that in itself was an
incredible endeavor i saw by katie and
completely obviously drew me well one i
was baffled by the idea of actually
holding a film with someone like emma so
that in itself was quite an honor to
even be considered
but yeah just seeing this young man i
think in the modern world and and seeing
his ownership over what he does and his
love for what he does was something that
really touched me
um and
yeah he had so much to kind of say for
himself that i just i felt i wanted to
yeah experience that but for me it was
quite daunting i think holding this film
was
uh exciting at the same time
yeah you did a great job so you guys
both had such great chemistry and sophie
i want to talk about that
and what was the process that it came to
i mean you came to the project and
emma's already attached but what was it
like directing her and daryl and seeing
that chemistry and working with that
look i mean it was a great
great pleasure like it was thrilling
every day to to work with these two and
in terms of chemistry like i always find
it a
an interesting question because you you
do need a chemistry and and and the way
that we were um emma and i started
talking about finding leo was that there
needed to be something that worked
between them do you know that we needed
to find that but i also really believe
that actors you know are skillful people
who come together and create chemistry
do you know that that is part of their
job and they do it very well and so i
have a great deal of trust in that and
part of my job as a director is to set
up the parameters for that to be able to
happen so um
for us you know we had the such an
incredible experience of being able to
have some time in a rehearsal room um
just the three of us um and that meant
that we could
explore things that you might not
normally get a chance to explore if you
just go straight into the script you
know we did a lot of talking we did a
lot of playing around you know we did a
lot of exploring what we felt about our
own bodies and and our own lives and and
exploring what the characters had been
going through
and so
for me by the time we got into set
we were already a team and these two
were certainly already a team and so we
were able to um together lead the film
through and make it like that
yeah it really comes off in the in the
final product
so uh daryl my question for you is about
portraying the sex worker i know that
you said you worked you spoke with some
people who work in the industry um what
was the best advice that you got from
this experience and in portraying leo
and from the from the people working in
the industry yeah i mean we were so
blessed to have a compiled list of sex
workers to speak to um that was
organized by sophie and the team and
i don't know if there was any particular
advice
but it was more kind of
getting to know them as individuals
and their spirit kind of rubbed off on
me and and that for me was what i kind
of hoped to not misrepresent in the film
and carry into the process of making the
film
um
but yeah it was just their ownership
over themselves their autonomy their
authority and their
love for what they do their vocation um
but i yeah i just got to speak to each
one individually and get to know them
and just that was an honor in itself um
and i was just
bringing their energy hopefully into the
film yeah well i think that energy
definitely came off especially with the
confidence and with the
self-assuredness of him in his career so
i i appreciated that
um and emma i really enjoyed you playing
this role and watching nancy's character
slowly sort of unfold and grow as the
film progressed it was actually really
exciting to see her
take on leo's uh words and change for
herself
what do you hope for
people especially women going into
watching this film who might relate with
nancy on some level maybe not the orgasm
thing i hope for you know many of these
women um what do you hope they take away
from
the from nancy's journey the desire to
talk about female pleasure
no female pleasure is not something that
is considered important in our society
and if it is it's only being sold but
essentially for male pleasure in my view
i think it's very rare that female
pleasure is genuinely examined genuinely
discussed um i think that we live in
like it or not in our societies in
america and in in the west and we're
built on christian values and christian
values have traditionally
um
denied and indeed prohibited female
pleasure that's not the point um and and
actually you know the growth of sex work
came out it's men who pay for sex it's
generally speaking not women who pay for
sex so
um
and that's because women aren't supposed
to
feel pleasure or um have appetites
actually of any kind we're not even
supposed to eat much um ideally it would
be good if we just ate less and within
and um didn't want didn't demand um so
you know nancy's grown up i think very
much in that world and she's she's all
of those shapes that i was talking about
before the roles that women are supposed
to take on uh she slowly finds herself
challenging and what's interesting is
she's challenging herself
you know it's it's it's the fact that
she's in a room with someone she might
never see again with whom she has
no point of
of common ground except
their deep shared humanity and their
curiosity about one another which is a
very mutual thing and so through that
sort of discovery she starts to meet
herself on the way
and she says things that are deeply
taboo
for instance she says i'm not sure i
would have been a mother if i was given
the choice people don't want to hear
that nobody wants to hear
women say they don't want to be mothers
because that's just destructive to
everything that we hold dear you know
everything that we have in our romantic
movies and all and in all our stories
your women have to be nurturing and the
mother and if they're not and they say
they don't want to be mothers it's very
very challenging for us
so you're watching a whole system being
dismantled by these two people in one
room so the changes that happen are
seismic it's not a gentle thing it's
massive you know that's what's so
exciting about it and you can see it and
feel it as though you're in the ocean
with these people because
all you have is two people and a camera
so it's it's pure it's the kind of one
of the purest cinema jobs i've ever done
yeah i really i really appreciated those
moments of like
extreme honesty because i feel like
there's definitely even if women don't
feel like it all of the time there's
definitely been moments where it's like
oh my god like why did i have these
children like why is my life walking
down this path so i really enjoyed
exploring that and seeing her very
honest
reaction to it and just
this perhaps this life unlimited
especially that flashback or not
flashback but when she's recounting that
story
of her family on vacation i really like
that scene that was like a very intimate
and also
introspective scene for her so i i
really appreciated that um yeah and
sophie i just wanted to ask you about
directing
in that small room and sort of the
semantics that went into it and how how
that came about
it was always it was always set in one
room and when you get a script like that
that's deeply exciting do you know
you're like oh my god just to act like
all that like that's heaven for me i'm
like great we can just really explore
what's going on with them and and their
bodies their gesture like those things
become the thing um and then
second thought you're like oh [ __ ]
like two people in one room like
how the hell are we going to make this
beautiful and vicious and
you know um and also not to you know you
don't want to go for something that's
too fancy but not too
trashy do you know like finding that
balance of
that room you know and and what we
brought in from the outside um was
important so light became really
important in it you know how we use the
light and how the light changes over the
time that we're in there
obviously these two and where they go
and what they do and we had the i we we
we blocked it more than i think i've
ever blocked something before or
anything nice like we were really sure
about where you were um thankfully um
these two spent a lot of time like going
over lines and they could do
you know we would do 12 minute takes so
12 pages of dialogue and these guys
would just
perform it like it was a beautiful play
do you know um but then the camera team
would have to find shots that looked
good that whole time you know so it was
quite a dance you know and i think it's
deceptively simple a film like this you
know it's um
you're just managing this they're sort
of
moderating their journey but also you
know the the audience and how intimate
the audience feels you know we start out
kind of much wider and a bit here a bit
kind of
viewing them and we sort of slowly find
our way into kind of being more handheld
or more free with the camera and um and
that helps us sort of get in there but i
mean i loved every second truly like
being on a set is amazing right you're
like there every day and all you're
thinking about is the performance you're
not going like
oh we've got to move to blah blah blah
and two out you know all of that stuff
gets to drop away and as emma said the
pure cinema of it comes back which is
humanity like people how we deal with
each other how we treat each other yeah
i really liked those scenes especially
of
you know i was watching it and i was
like oh i i love movies where it's just
two characters talking
and i was
excited to see that it was that type of
story but i was also like oh wow this
must have been an extreme challenge to
film and it's i'm glad that it was so
successful because it definitely you can
feel the intimacy
and the
and the conversation between those
characters it feels like you're just a
fly on the wall in that room which is i
think was the intent of the film
yeah um
i want to talk a little bit about the
nudity in the film that we sort of feel
like it feels like it's a part that
we're always sort of moving towards and
that intimacy that she hasn't achieved
yet that nancy hasn't achieved yet and
i want to talk especially with emma
about
how it felt to
to film some of those scenes towards the
end especially when she's sort of
embraced her sexuality and she's kind of
achieved this i mean
a climactic no pun intended part of her
life um i want to talk about just how
that felt for you as an actor
and
how that worked logistically you know
filming-wise you know
we were very lucky because i mean as a
team we were very lucky because sophie
and daryl and i at the right at the
beginning we were lucky we had was it
three days though
how many days rehearsal
two what five was it oh my god okay
totally forgotten um
and
and during one of those days we just
rehearsed naked we all took our clothes
off
and we talked about our bodies how we
felt about our bodies um
and after you know
at first it feels odd and then of course
it doesn't feel odd because it isn't in
fact hard
it's just not odd to be naked and human
in a room together and you know people
in in other countries understand that
but our countries are very puritanical
and odd about nudity which is why we're
having this discussion you know when we
open the film in norway no one's going
to ask us any questions about nudity
because they're just constantly taking
their clothes off and rushing into
[Laughter]
and germany i bet you it doesn't happen
even in berlin because they they just
it's taken as a matter of course but we
our culture and which is the where the
film is placed is odd about it so we
addressed it first of all very
practically in that way and that was
incredibly helpful for me because whilst
obviously daryl is completely perfect
and it's like having a [ __ ] unicorn
in the room you know i'm not and i'm 62
and i haven't taken my clothes off since
i got naked with jeff goldblum when i
was in my 20s
um and
so
that that was
you know but we shot in order by the
time we got to the end
um daryl and i knew each we were sort of
we'd held each other's hands
through this so
we told each other you know
contained one another and looked after
one another to such a degree our
intimacy was so great
that having no clothes was neither here
nor there
and interestingly and i think this is
so
will understand this very very well the
most difficult thing that i had to do in
the movie was to be naked on my own in
front of the mirror
because um i realized when i was doing
it that it was something i had never
done
in my life i had never stood in front of
a mirror
with no particular judgment
not with approval i mean she's nancy's
not looking at herself with approval and
saying boy woof look at that sexy
goddess she's just looking at herself
without judging herself
i mean i challenge any woman to do that
and actually do it without moving her
body around to look um how can i change
this to make it look better how can i
treat this and the fact of the matter is
we're not used to seeing untreated
bodies on the screen
and and this that was the hardest thing
i've ever had to act because i had to
ask someone who wasn't
concerned
who was
accepting
it was very difficult
and but because i was with sophie and
brian
who just was so brilliant at knowing
exactly what's brilliant about it is
that this is all in the edit there was
never too much there's never too much
nudity it's never like oh that's a
little bit
too much it's very very subtly done and
the moment where she's looking at
herself is short enough
that you just go oh
and it's quite shocking but it's also
incredibly
well i find it very touching
yeah yeah i i agree i think that was one
of the
one of the best scenes of the movie
because i feel like so often
when it comes to women's bodies
especially in media it's just so
it's just everybody has an opinion you
know and they want you to have that
opinion as well and like how dare you
not have that opinion about yourself and
criticize yourself and judge yourself
and
how dare you not immediately accept
yourself as well like why do you see the
flaws like you're perfect so i i really
like that and you i could see that like
complexity that was playing off
especially in your face and especially
in that sort of even in the posture in
the stance i'm sort of like well i have
to accept this part of myself but it's
also a journey
and it's an experience
so i yeah i really appreciated that and
i really appreciate
exploring that journey with yourself
being intimate and because you know
that's
you know not to give away
plots points but yes it's it's about
being with yourself and being able to
live with yourself too in some ways
right
yeah completely you know we're also
we're taught so much to hate our bodies
you know and all the opposite is like we
love our bodies how beautiful are they
kind of thing and there's this in
between that i think nancy finds at the
end of the film which is
that
her body does something is there for
another reason it's not there to be
looked at her body in that moment is not
there for someone else's view and what
she's learned through this process with
leo is that her body she's allowed to
have wants and she's allowed to have
pleasure and and her body can do things
for her that aren't about anyone else
and certainly aren't about how it looks
so that moment for me of looking in the
mirror is about this body is not just
for someone else's vision or as a photo
somewhere or for my instagram feed or to
be all the things someone else thinks i
should be it's got me through my whole
life it's got me an orgasm even now do
you know
it's like your body is there for more
than just visuals yeah
that's what i mean and and more than
just for somebody else's
life you know i think her role as a
teacher and as a mother and all these
things
serve other people and it's very obvious
you know when we see in
the earlier parts of the film that she's
like oh my god like i'm so sorry this is
you know this is i should just go like
this that felt very much like okay this
is like this i can i can understand this
sort of feeling if a woman is like okay
i'm sorry i'll just leave that's fine
like sorry to bother you even though i
paid for your services
um
but i thought another interesting aspect
of this film is also
perhaps not the objectification but the
embrace of youth in
in the film because obviously daryl you
play you know your younger character and
she says in the film like oh yeah like i
can get other guys my age but that's not
what i want like i want someone youthful
and i want to feel young
what did it feel like
working on the story and kind of
understanding that that was your role
and embracing that you know he has that
confidence that
i feel like a lot of young men don't
have
and they he has this understanding of
the female body and of
the female experience in a way that
people men might not have and what was
that like exploring that part of that
character wow an interesting question
yeah i mean i think it all came from the
script and the research that we did with
sophie but there was a lot of those kind
of
you know as a young man in the world
right now there's a lot of those kind of
sentences that came from leo that i was
like wow you know these are
conversations i'm trying to have my
friends that i feel are
on the cusp of new ways of thinking or
like you know i'm trying to encourage
more men to kind of see this and and to
see this
fully realized young man
not just having them but really owning
them and being able to own them in a
sense to kind of
part them with someone else who's you
know discovering them as well so
i thought it was incredibly fresh to see
that in a young man
but also in terms of we don't get to see
a lot of leo's personal life outside of
his profession
but i
gathered that that was where he you know
we have our own backstories for that but
for me personally that was where he
would have
obtained that you know and that's
through his own experience of
putting him out there himself out there
sexually and the the lessons that we get
by you know making ourselves vulnerable
in that way so
but yeah i i thought it was incredibly
like um
inspiring to see a young man portrayed
in that way
um because i think it's often that we
don't see men with these
you know
who are just uh
self-aware enough you know
um so
i felt very privileged to be able to
be be someone to play that kind of
self um aware and
current man is that is that right like
uh yeah
yeah this is a young man who i hope to
see other young young men have
you know those thoughts and those
to come to those realizations themselves
um
yeah it was quite exciting
i just want to ask a little bit about
the filming process during covid did
that play a factor into any of this um
into the planning of the film into the
shooting
i mean brian who's this pneumatographer
and editor and i we flew from australia
where there was like zero covert at the
time
the middle of the uk and locked down and
every plague was raging
everyone was wearing those pointy nose
things
and and you know we're all crossing the
street to avoid one another incense
bells banging
but she's not joking
and so scary going over and then you get
there and you're like everyone's in
lockdown so you can't go out right but
you
there's so many protocols that come in
so our set you know of course we had
masks and all of those things and um
i couldn't go drinking in pubs or
anything could we but um you know the
because we had such a small set and
these two were already in a bubble you
sort of forgot that quite quickly you
were just doing your nose swabs and
getting down to business i think
yeah i think for us as well we had our
own accommodation and we were about 15
minute walk to set and so every morning
obviously where we arrive at the same
time we leave the same time so for us it
was quite amazing to actually have a
city that was in a lockdown
because the film is so intimate and the
kind of focus that we kind of had to
have every day um
obviously started when we got to set but
in a way we were able to have that
because
there was a whole city that was a little
bit less awake you know in terms of open
and and so we had kind of free roam and
were able to
i guess have that locked down with
ourselves throughout the whole process
of the film so i think that was a
particular gift i think
um that covered gave us
oh no i've forgotten about that but
daryl's right because
when you went back he said it was just
odd because we had it was so quiet you
know we'd be up
early in the morning we'd walk to work
we'd work all day we'd walk home we
wouldn't go out with anyone like you
would normally say well to the crew on a
friday night or something maybe let's go
out we never did that and the one day we
had off because we were doing six day
weeks of course only 19 days shoot so on
that sunday we'd go
take the car and go and walk on the
beach and do our lines and or just be
silent or cook a meal so we lived in in
a kind of
very
confined space which
actually helped us because
there's a lot of lines so every night
we'd have to go through the next
and
there's sort of acts almost aren't there
so there was an awful lot it was very
intense but
i think it did help us in a way it
really did yeah that's so that's so true
there was such a ritual i think every
day because you know even the
the privilege to walk the set you know
yeah was amazing there was such a
ritualistic kind of process of making
the whole film that actually by the time
because we would walk together we would
talk about what we were about to shoot
we would shoot that day and then we
would talk about how we shot that and
then we would go home and rehearse the
lines for the next day and then we would
just repeat that process for three weeks
yeah and so by the time we get to the
end of the film where you see leo nancy
really intimate one another myself and
emma were totally safe in each other's
hands you know um and was it shot in
order
were you guys doing it all in order oh
okay
wow amazing i mean that's
that kind of feels like so immersive of
an experience and it feels it was
immersive absolutely
yeah
yeah was there any improv with the lines
or was it totally like just right off
the script when you guys were talking
when you guys were doing filming those
scenes together
we weren't improvising we did a lot of
work outside of the script you know just
exploring and certainly there were times
where in the rehearsal room we would
adjust things or
things like that right like um
there was no moment where it was like
you guys go for it and we'll find it in
the edit
no there was no room really for
improvisation i mean it's very
very um the fact that we were prepared
no way i had to learn so much of it
before we started you couldn't come to
that and go hey well let's just deal
with the material let's just be loose no
there was no no it was tight as a duck's
arse that shoot there was no room for
any maneuver whatsoever i mean the sofa
will tell you you know we were really
honest if we hadn't known it
absolutely know what we were doing
forget it we would never have shot it in
the time i mean it was up to the wire
wasn't it safe right that last shot
we've just about had time to make the
sodding thing yeah you know
everything and there was have no wasted
time at all no and if there weren't two
actors who
learnt all their lines and could do that
in that amount like those long long
takes we just couldn't have done it you
just there are some things that can't be
done but luckily we did you know and
they worked really hard during the shoot
to keep those lines and and that to be
able to perform at that level and and be
remembering all of that at the same time
you know there's a high pressure in some
ways
yeah
yeah well again like i said the final
product shows off all the hard work that
you guys did and i really really did
enjoy it you know like i feel like i
went on this journey with nancy and i'm
very proud of her for her growth and i'm
like excited for leo's future and i want
all these things for these characters
and i want them to succeed so i feel
like
that was a good takeaway to take away
from this film that was also very uh
funny too the humor was amazing so i
really want to thank you guys for
speaking with me today and i hope people
get to watch this film and yeah thank
you
thank you very much thanks so much thank
you very much